welcome I'm Yvonne I'm the CEO of puppet
and it is such a privilege to be here
today
puppet has long been a huge believer in
open source in fact the founder of
puppet Luca nice he wrote the first code
of the puppet open-source project back
in 2005 four years before we were
actually founded as a company and it has
continued to grow and scale over time we
have over 4,000 organizations that have
benefited from puppet technology we have
an amazing content repository called the
forge with over 6000 open source modules
created by many folks likely out here in
the audience and beyond
we have over 160 thousand unique
visitors to that we've also started a
lot of other interesting open source
projects like bolts Lehrer wash we
contribute upstream now to Tecton in
terms of some of our cloud native
offerings so it's been really important
to us to be part of this community and
thrilled to see it continue to thrive
from a what do we do perspective there
were a lot of hands but a brief
description I like to say we eliminate
soul-crushing work and we do that
through infrastructure automation and
integrating into environments to take
away the toil of having to do everything
manually but also to make your
environments more scalable and more
secure to that end we also created
something called the state of the DevOps
report we've been doing that for over
nine years thanks to many of you who've
contributed to that we have over 30,000
individuals who participate send in
their feedback and what I want to do
today is share with you some of the
highlights from the most recent survey
and really call to your attention that
each and every one of you and all of us
collectively have a role to play in
security talk about why that's important
and talk about what you can practically
tactically do and to kind of re
emphasize why it's important there was a
stat earlier ninety I think was 99% of
software contains open source and we
just heard from IBM there's a lot of
places where we can be vulnerable so
let's talk about that hopefully many of
you recognize the headlines up on the
screen these are initially that we saw
these as you know wow I feel really bad
for the folks at Target but don't be
fooled
some Forrester research showed that 58%
of companies have had a date of breach
and 41% of those come from software
vulnerabilities so we're not as safe as
we think that we would be there's
British Airways t-mobile Facebook you
can go on and on and on but at the end
of the day there's many many folks who
have now been impacted and the reality
is this cause folks a lot of money
so in target's case it was eighteen
point five million dollars in Equifax it
was 650 million and the list goes on and
on and that doesn't even start to
account for the brand's impact the
customer loyalty all of those other
challenges but even just the average
ransomware attack five million dollars
so the reason why people are starting to
get concerned about this is this could
cost a lot of money but it gets worse if
you think about it there's more types of
data most of the breaches today have
been about personal information about
security numbers and things like that
but if you think about it all different
types of data are being stored in all
different types of places and they're
controlling more things they're driving
your cars they're managing your money
they're potentially dispensing the
medicines to your parents all of those
things imagine if a bad actor got in and
again we heard about all the places a is
gonna play a role so there's more at
risk so not only is there more
technology more surface area for bad
actors but there's more impact that they
can have the other thing that's changed
is how software's are developed and I
believe all of these things are good
it's more democratized it's more
decentralized and it's increasing
open source and all of that is fabulous
but it does mess with security because
in the olden days we cared about the
perimeter we kind of thought it was like
our house like you put a lock on the
door you shut the windows and you're
safe we used to keep all of our software
in these data centers and we protected
the perimeter but we now realize that
that is insufficient and it's causing us
to think about how do we actually keep
the world safe and I want to share with
you some stats on open source because I
think this is particularly relevant this
comes from our friends at sneaked an
open source security startup look at
these stats 88% growth and application
vulnerabilities in over two years 78% of
those vulnerabilities were found in
indirect dependencies so we don't always
think about when we include a call to an
open source package what that might be
introducing into our ecosystem 37% of
open source developers I'm sure that's
not any of you but 37% don't include any
type of security testing during the CI
process and 54% don't do any docker
image security screens
it's a median of two years from when a
vulnerability is found or added in an
open source package until it's fixed
that's a long time to be vulnerable and
companies all over the globe it was said
earlier 99% of software includes open
source this is scary now coming from
puppet I'm going to tell you I believe
automation and declarative models are
foundation to security if they're not
sufficient I do want to point out that
they are important I hi it was talking
to a bank and they had a huge amount of
stability issues they did a
retrospective and they said don't write
this down so I didn't write it down but
I did remember it
they said 80% of the issues they had
were human error it was fat fingering it
was failure to adhere to policy it was
not getting work done in a critical
amount of time and so what they realized
is they needed to automate the
environment to actually create a
level of foundation of not just
standardization and reliability but also
security but that's far from sufficient
in terms of what we need to do and this
is where the whole concept of DevOps has
started to shift to dev suck-ups so if
we think about it Waterfall broke down
because it was this serial process it
took too long there were too many
handoffs it was not gratifying to have
to wait months and months and months to
see and get feedback on what you'd
written and that was all great but we
moved to DevOps and we moved to
containers or we moved to micro services
to actually further improve and increase
the ability that we can deliver feature
functionality to the marketplace but
what we didn't account for necessarily
was security now this shouldn't surprise
anybody but this comes from IBM and if
you look at the cost of fixing defects
if you wait until implementation to find
the defect it's six and a half times as
expensive testing 15 if it's found after
the fact it's a hundred times more
expensive so it starts to raise the
question if security really is this
important and it's this constantly to
fix after the fact should we blend it in
sooner so last year when we did the
state of the DevOps report we came up
with a five stages of evolution
normalized standardized expansion
automated delivery and then ultimately
self-service if you look at it in the
final stages is when you start to see
companies integrating in security when
they start looking at security policy
configurations being automated when you
look at Incident Response being
automated and when you look at security
teams being involved in the process what
we found not surprisingly this year is
that in terms of the ability to have
high levels of security integration it
is in level four and five it is those
most most sophisticated companies and
organizations out there
and here are some of the things that
they're doing across the lifecycle from
a requirement standpoint actually
thinking about compliance and security
in the beginning during requirements
doing threat modeling as you work
through the design lots of areas in the
build process that you can do things
from a testing standpoint from a
deployment so there's many different
areas where you can start to build
security in as part of the process and
break down those barriers now what we
found when we went on we talked to folks
is that when you increase the level of
collaboration you actually increase the
confidence in the security posture of a
company now what does that look like
well if we if we look at how mature
companies are companies that are level
four or five in terms of the maturity of
DevOps have a 2x time higher level of
confidence than level 1 on the security
posture in the company what are some of
the things that they're doing
first and foremost they're actually
collaborating on threat models that's
key they're integrating security tools
in the integration pipeline they're
prioritizing security requirements in
the backlog they're understanding the
infrastructure related security policies
before deployment and they're actually
involving the security experts in the
automated tests so these are the things
that they're doing now that doesn't
necessarily mean they're more secure but
it is a mindset shift it is a breaking
down of the walls and the silos just
like we did between development and
operations we're now doing that with
security teams and unfortunately what we
found is just like when you go on the
DevOps journey itself security
integration is messy whenever you try
something new and you're trying to
change behaviors we talked about going
through what we like to say a j-curve
you get some quick early wins then it
starts to get more complex and then you
get the real benefit
and we see that in the data we went out
we talked to security teams and
developers around the level of friction
and what you'll see is not surprisingly
people who don't integrate it all don't
see very much friction okay they're also
probably not very secure if you go to
the far end level five there's actually
they're the lowest amount of friction
perceived and it's in the middle section
where you see the greatest amount of
friction because that's where you're
just learning how to work together
you're learning how to integrate these
processes now why is there friction
let's go back to why we did DevOps it
was to get feature functionality out
quicker and if we talked to respondents
the security slowed you down and I think
that's been the big challenge all along
the security slowed you down and if you
look at the chart if you're not really
focused on it you don't really think
about it Security's not slowing you down
because you're not doing it and if you
go to the fully integrated side you've
kind of figured it out but in the middle
it's somewhat messy I'm here to tell you
as a CEO of a company that sells to
Fortune you know 1,000 companies around
the globe security matters my phone
rings if there's any issue and so when I
talk to my engineering teams yes I care
about future functionality but I also
care about the security and the ability
that we can bring to our customers to
ensure that they're not at risk
particularly in this increasingly
challenging world when it comes to
cybersecurity so how are people doing
well if we look at it in terms of a
measure of remediation of critical
vulnerabilities we're doing okay if you
look at the dark blue bar I know the
numbers are a little bit small what
you'll see is that level 5 DevOps
companies can actually remediates
critical vulnerabilities in less than a
day it's a little actually to say about
half of the vulnerabilities and then it
kind of trails off over time so this is
not where we need it to be but it
definitely improves the ability to
remediate the vulnerabilities and
hopefully there's fewer of them getting
in to begin with
so in terms of integrating security it
does leave to positive outcomes it is an
important responsibility for all of us
to have and to take to heart but it's
not going to come easily and so it's a
responsibility that we need to bring to
the table and bring forward in terms of
the work that we're doing so how do you
improve your security profile overall we
break it up into three key buckets this
is mostly the infrastructure layer in
terms of how do you ensure you're
creating an automated environment that
ideally provides self-service from a
developer perspective how do you mature
your DevOps practices and move to dev
sack ops and how do you remediate the
vulnerabilities faster and on this last
point this isn't one simple answer in
today's world this typically is the
integration of your toolset in your
activities with other things in the
environment it can be anything from
integration with the security scanners
that you have to drive automated
remediation it can be integration into
workflow tools like ServiceNow or its
Splunk or other tools like that but how
do you reduce that time because right
now the time to remediate
vulnerabilities if you already know
there's a vulnerability that's the last
thing you want to get hit on in terms of
a security breach so with that I invite
all of you to download our most recent
state of the DevOps report you can find
it for free on the puppet website along
with all the past reports and if you
have any questions I'll be around for
the rest of the conference and look
forward to seeing you thank you so much
[Applause]